stop stop just close the door stop close
it close the door come on just close
Jesus [ __ ] huh hey guys we're gonna jump
into some five nights at Freddy's VR
help-wanted which is a mix of some of
the five nights at freddy games but in
VR and I'm terrified
so let's go let's get bebop five dots
Freddy's do this looks way too real I
don't like this oh I like fight them go
hard so awful okay Vicki look behind me
- this is this that's upsetting me you
should cut this is horrible I haven't
even done anything yet
ah this sucks
I knew it oh sorry oh god I'm in a game
this guy like a big chunk Asst oh no no
no no no stop I'm not ready for this
[ __ ] oh oh they're gonna come through
the vents oh hell no I'm so stressed out
on me uh-huh go somewhere else oh okay
hey Chris yeah I can't do this this this
oh you know when I was a child I've been
to chuck-e-cheeses a couple times and
during that time you know I recall I
having a dandy old time there was you I
want to see you [ __ ] just Oh God
what I do wanna know the creepy [ __ ]
they left these here on the wall
Oh what is that no I've had enough
cancer the audio off god damn it
oh my god what what oh no I know
got it
yeah animatronics can't kill you thank
you for letting me know that this is so
horrible I'm having such a horrible time
no God okay
[Music]
[Music]
no you know what no I win game over this
back into the deep horrible unknown a
five nights at my golden Freddy I'm
having a bad time guff holy [ __ ] huh
okay okay so that's the okay so how can
I can I golf can they leave stop
just take the cup take take your
[ __ ] garbage have a gradle danny
night media okay you oh no no no no no
something's still there good stop just
go home oh I may not be at time is that
like real that's real I'm okay this is
horrible
medic such a bad side Oh God uh can I
just what is that what is that my eyes
are closed
my eyes are closed Oh are we over is it
done
I never wanna see that again okay my
name is Kurt and I want to die but now
I'm alive
thanks everyone death sucked